Paul then takes the armor of the Roman
soldiers
and breaks them down showing you that
you too are a soldier. You too have that
armor. And he tells you which
piece of that armor worn by a soldier
applies to you in a spiritual sense.
Ephesians 6:12-18.
But I'll start here. I'll start from 10,
right?
Ephesians 6:12-18, but we're going to
start here. Okay, watch here. He takes
the imagery of the Roman soldier and his
armor and he spiritualizes it, saying,
"You are soldiers, too." Finally, be
strong in the Lord and in the might of
his strength. Notice, he's giving you
the power. You're not doing it alone.
The Lord is supplying you his power. And
the less you sin, the more you obey, the
more power he'll give you as opposed to
disciplining you.
You got it?
Yes,
Chile. And I'll show you that. Put on
the full armor of God. See, the Bible
tells you why you do. So when the
problem, why do you keep praying?
Because why do you keep weightlifting
and going to the gym every day doing the
same exercises? Why do you keep running
every day? Oh, it's because I need to
keep doing it to stay fit. Let's
continue.
So that you will be able to stand firm
against schemes and because you're in a
warfare. Notice you're battling the king
of Satan. But he's not attacking you.
This is the wrong imagery. You're
attacking him. The Lord came in ter
enemy territory, enemy camp to declare
allout war to destroy the enemy and his
army and to take back what he stole from
God's people. You're in an offensive
spiritual military war. You're declaring
war. You're not waiting for Satan.
You're chasing after Satan to destroy
his kingdom.
Rewire your brain.
Rewire your brain. What do I mean? Stop
thinking you're the victim who's being
attacked. That's not the imagery in the
Bible. Sonia, good to see you. It's been
a while, sister. Are you with me there?
Let me repeat. Rumble
and Facebook and YouTube. Rewire your
brain. You are not the victim being
attacked by Satan. Wrong. You are the
warriors, the lions, lionesses. You're
on the march. You are chasing after
Satan. You're declaring war and assault
on his kingdom. That's the imagery.
That's the imagery.
That's the Bible's teaching. It's not
me. Here, I'll show you from our Lord.
Right? For our struggle is not against
flesh and blood, but against the rulers,
against the authorities, against the
world forces of this darkness. That's
who we're declaring war against. Satan's
kingdom, his influence,
against the spiritual force, wickedness
in the heavenly place. Therefore, here's
your armor. Take up the full armor of
God. Your armor is unbreakable.
Satan cannot destroy your armor, but he
tries to strip you of your armor by
having you not put it on completely or
know how to use it correctly. Watch
here. So that you'll be able to resist
in the evil day. And having done
everything, you stand firm. Stand firm,
therefore, here's your armor. Having
girded your loins with truth. Right?
What did the Roman soldiers have? They
would gird themselves with a
breastplate. Right?
having put on the breastplate of
righteousness. See, these are your
pieces of armor, knowing the truth,
walking in the truth, proclaiming the
truth, being righteous and just, living
righteously,
shod your feet with the preparation of
the gospel of peace. He's even talking
about the type of shoes that the Roman
soldiers would wear in battle.
What are your shoes? Your shoes are
running shoes to run
and preach the gospel everywhere. In
addition to all, having taken up the
shield of faith. What's your shield to
protect you from being struck down by
the enemy's arrows and darts? Your faith
in Christ. Your faithfulness to Christ.
Your assurity that Christ is Lord and
he's for you and he loves you. If you
are in him and confessing him and not
doubting him
with which you are able to extinguish
all the flaming arrows of the evil one
also receive the helmet of salvation.
Your helmet is the fact that God has
given you a great salvation.
You put on a helmet knowing knowing
helmet meaning your mind knowing you
have been bought by the blood of Jesus
and our Lord is more than a conqueror
who destroyed death the grave and Satan
and never doubting it. You see see the
pieces of your armor.
And what is your sword? The word of God.
See your armor
also prayer.
See why you do rope prayer. Praying at
all times with all prayer and petition
the spirit letting the spirit move you
and guide you to pray ceaselessly.
These are your weapons and the pieces of
your armor.
And to this end being on the alert with
all perseverance and petition for all
the saints. Pray
for all the saints. Pray for one
another. Why do you think I keep asking
you to pray for me? And Paul says also
pray for me as well as my behalf. Pray
so that the spirit right will give me
the words to utter that words may be
given to me and opening my mouth to make
known with boldness not to be afraid or
timid the mystery of the gospel for
which I'm an ambassador in chains so
that I'm proclaiming it I may speak
boldly as I ought to speak not timidly.
That's your armor, right?
See that?
Praying
everyone got it.
So there you go.
So the Bible has given you everything
you need to succeed. It has all your
answers. You may not like the answers,
but it's there.
What is your sword again?
That Holy Spirit has given you to crush
the enemy. God's word. But now, what
does Satan do? He can't destroy the
armor. He cannot destroy the weapons,
but he tries to strip you of it. Let me
show you his mindset before we begin.
Let me show you his mindset. He knows he
can't destroy the sword from the spirit.
He can't destroy the helmet or the
shield. He can't. But so what does he
do? Knowing he can't destroy it, he
tries to strip you of it. How? By
causing you to stop praying.
Now he removed one piece of your armor.
By causing you to stop focusing on God's
word, he now stripped you of another
piece of your armor by causing you to
doubt
your faith. Doubt whether Christianity
is true. Doubt whether Jesus is Lord.
Doubt whether you're really saved. This
is how he slowly strips you of your
armor.
Right?
And also
by causing you not to proclaim the
gospel of peace to those around you.
Being indifferent.
You see how it works?
See it?
He can't destroy your armor.
Your armor is unbreakable invincible
because it's the armor from God and he's
almighty. Satan's not. He can strip you
of it.
So the less you pray, the weaker you
are. He now stripped you of that. The
less you're in God's word, meditating on
God's word, he stripped you of your
sword. When you start doubting whether
you're saved or start doubting whether
Christ is even real and you're doubting
your faith, he stripped you of that. See
how he's doing it?
This is it. So now that was just a
reminder. One more thing before we begin
because I I want to make sure to remind
my this is not just a reminder for you.
It's for me. I need to practice what I
preach.
And by the way,
since Satan knows there's warfare, he
goes and looks for the most dangerous
soldier to take him out of the
battlefield.
He knows it's warfare. He knows Christ
has come declared war on his kingdom and
we are the soldiers. So if he can take
out the dangerous, the most deadly
soldier, that's one victory. So he looks
for the one who's most dangerous to him
to try to tempt him to fail Jesus and
now is of no use and no threat.
You understand?
But now watch here.
Let me show you this.
James 4:es 4 to8.
You adulterers or adulteresses,
do you not know that friendship of the
world is enemy toward God?
The world is influenced by Satan and
hates the things of God. Why do you want
the world's approval and appease the
world? Especially you philosophers out
there. Therefore, who wish whoever
wishes to be a friend of the world?
friend of the world sets himself as an
enemy of God. Or do you think that the
scriptures speak to no purpose? He
jealously desires the spirit which he
has made to dwell in us. What does that
mean? The Lord
is desirous
that that spirit that's in you
will so work in you and energize you by
your submission to the spirit because
it's only by the spirit in you you can
overcome. So do not resist the spirit.
You want me there?
That spirit that's in you, it's from
him, given to you to energize you. And
he eagerly desires the spirit to have
his way with you.
You understand what it means here? He
eagerly desires the spirit to fully
possess you so that it's no longer you
acting, it's the spirit acting through
you. Because if you let the spirit take
complete control of you, you cannot fall
ever
with me there.
But he gives a greater grace to who? Who
does he give more favor to? There says
God is opposed to the proud but gives
grace to the humble. That's it right
there.
Who does he give more favor to? Who's he
more patient with, more compassionate
with? Right.
Love and pizza. I'm giving it to you
right now, buddy.
All right.
Who?
Right here. You ready? Are you ready?
All right.
The humble.
But be subject therefore to God. Why?
Because when you humble yourself and
submit to God, you will then resist
resist the devil's temptations and he
will not just walk away. He'll run from
you, flee from you like a coward. Right?
Draw near to God. He'll draw near to
you. Cleanse your hands, you sinners.
Meaning, purify yourself from being
defiled by the stains of the world. And
stop being double-minded. Meaning, stop
doubting God's goodness and faithfulness
and his will.
Stop. Because if you're double-minded,
you won't have certainty. And if you
won't have certainty, then you won't act
upon it because you're doubting.
See how it works? If I doubt whether
something is of God or something is
good, I won't act on it. So
double-mindedness hinders you and
handicaps you from taking God's word and
acting on it.
Right? Now, when I'm talking about God's
will, I'm talking about what he's
clearly said his will is for us when it
comes to living life. I know there are
other issues like
for example marriage and all that. Those
are things that God hasn't clearly
revealed to us
whether I will marry that young woman or
not. Whether God has I don't these are
things only known to him. But it's
talking about
God's revealed will and how you should
live to overcome Satan and then reign
with Christ forever. That is clear.
There's no doubt about that.
Is it making sense?
And let me ask you a question so you
understand how beautiful and deep our
Bible is.
How many of you when you have doubted
something, you're double-minded about
it. Should I do it? Should I not do it?
Can I really believe that this is from
God? Or maybe this is not God. When
you've had those doubts and
double-minded, have you ever been able
then to act upon God's word? And even
when you do, you've done it with great
trepidation and not trust. Right. Is
that not the truth?
Right.
This is why God says double-mindedness
is not from him. It's from your own
weakness, lack of trust, your sinful
flesh, and or Satan.
This is what he means. Why are you
doubting God's reality,
God's goodness, that Christ is alive?
Why do you doubt and that this is God's
word?
Because if you doubt, then you will not
have the confidence to act upon God's
will. A will that is intended
for your benefit, not harm. But you'll
never know
that this is meant for your benefit
because God, your father, loves you and
he knows what's best for you because he
created you. But he wants you to trust.